Eh c'est les vacances
Et cette année j'ai découvert la Grèce
J'ai eût cette chance
Je ne pouvais pas ne pas faire de vidéo
Eh Normal !
Ouai ça c'est le drapeau de la Grèce
Et je sais pas pourquoi j'ai toujours pensé que c'étais le drapeau de la Finlande
Du coup le premier jour ou je suis arrivé en Grèce
J'ai dit
Mais pourquoi ils mettent des drapeaux de la Finlande partout ?
Ca n'a aucun sens
C'est marrant quand j'ai annoncer à mes potes que j'allais dans la ville de Mykonos en Grèce,
ils m'ont tous fait la même blague, bien lourde :
Ah ouais tu vas dans la ville des PD
Comme je voulais qu'il n'y ai pas trop de mal entendu
Après quand ils me demandaient où j'allait en vacances
je répondais, je vais au Etats-Unis
dans un état très hétérosexuel
Par exemple le Texas
Là où il y pleins de cowboys très virils
Ah ouai des cowboys un peu comme dans le film brokeback mountain ?
Non non c'est pas les mêmes
Tu vois je suis du nord de la France, je suis Chti's
Et quand je suis arrivé dans la ville de myconos,
j'ai fait un rapprochement dans ma tête
Et je me suis dit : ah merde je suis un Chti's à Mykonos
(musique) les Chti's à Mykonos
c'es tpas du tout les bons accords
ce qui est incroyable chez les grecs
quand ils font du scooter ils ne portent pas de casque
ah un moment donné j'ai loué un scooter une journée
et j'ai loué un casque aussi
parce que bah pour la sécurité et que je suis habitué
et quand les grecs m'ont vu avec mon casque
ils me regardaient comme si j'étaient un extraterreste
même les policiers grecs me regardaient un peu chelou (bizarre)
Hop,hop,hop
c'est quoi ça ?
bah c'est un casque
ok ne bouger surtout pas
appel à toutes les unités un malade mental
se promène avec une boule sur la tête
Appelez des renforts
y'a certaines langues
comme l'espagnol, l'italien
l'anglais
ou même si tu parle pas forcément la langue
tu comprends un peu certains mots
en grèce ils utilisent un alphabet qu'on comprend pas du tout
qui n'existe pas du tout chez nous
ce qui assez handicapant
quand t'a besoin de faire des choix
Bon ben en entrée je vais prendre
boh bah au hasard allez, je vais prendre ça
d'accord monsieur
ah ouai, je me suis peut-être trompé de magasin en fait
en grèce il fait vraiment très chaud
c'est à dire que quand tu poses un pied dehors
ton pied brûle
mais ça a quand même certains aspects pratiques
Ca fait du bien une bonne douche froide
ah bah non c'est bon je suis sec
les grecs pour attirer les gens dans leurs restaurants
ils font un truc assez malin
ils t'ouvrent l'appétit
ils te donnent vraiment envie de manger
des cadavres de poulpes morts
c'est vrai que ça donne faim
évidement la question que tout le monde se pose et que je me suis posé
est-ce que les sandwichs grecs, les kebabs comme certains l'appel
sont meilleur en grèce qu'en france ?
est ce qu'ils ont l'air plus appétissant quand ils sont sur le rouleau
eh bien j'y suis allé et j'ai eût la réponse
non !!!
eh bien y'a vraiment des milliers de guêpes
des vraies guêpes
des putains de guêpes qui te piquent et qui font très très mal
eh bien y'en a partout
sauf que les grecs eux ils sont habitués
ça leurs pose aucun problème
ca les dérangent pas d'avoir des animaux qui peuvent peut-être les tuer
l'île d'andros c'est une île très sauvage
avec tout les feuillages, j'aime beaucoup là-bas aller manger des Kebabs tout
d'accord, d'accord
l'île de ouai c'est pas que je suis pas intéressé, y'a 36000 guêpes autour de moi
t'inquiète pas guêpes c'est un frelon
ah c'est un frelon, ah d'accord autant pour moi dans ce cas là y'a pas de soucis c'est tranquille
ouai t'inquiète pas va et tout d'un coup j'ai l'accent de Marseilles
Et là-bas c'est tout mes amis de MySpace
merci d'avoir regardé ma vidéo, n'oublier pas de vous abonnez à ma chaîne Youtube
Et moi il ne me reste plus qu'a vous dire au revoir
avec le seul mot que je sais dire e grèque : γειά σου